oh Boop illusoire ranawaka feckula buku
Don josé désigné avec le contrôle
ce sont Matthew nourris para la muerte de
propiedad sont mes trois théâtres dont vous avez
besoin sur mon propre porta potti coupe-arbre
elle est apparue compte moulin personne
Cassandra saucony Anya vidas se de
aplicar désarmer l'effort sur  la
sauce ooltewah des médias était sur le mec physiol les
citoyens bâillent même l'outil Maki Maki au
clair de lune Sri dilandau ils sont un organe
est matériel un étudiant même ma affaire
contre les armes à feu y groupe SI lobizon dcd creuser
facile Pola nous notons qu'Apollo plaisir peut faire
apparaître un massage approfondi cette élection  a
été si sauvage et si incontrôlable que
certains des problèmes les plus importants comme
le contrôle des armes à feu ont pris du retard et
ils ne reçoivent pas le genre de couverture,
alors nous essayons de faire avec toutes nos
actions est de mettre l'accent sur  des aspects
de la chaîne de la mort de l'industrie des armes à feu
que la plupart des gens ne connaissent pas,
c'est juste que c'est qu'il y a un silence
autour de cela, ce que nous voyons à travers le
pays, c'est la police  un abus de leur
autorité beaucoup de communautés de couleur
sont brutalisées par leurs propres services de
police qui sont armés et
dangereux et qui tirent sur les gens simplement à
cause de leur couleur de peau et donc l'une
des choses que nous pouvons faire est d'engager le
public la loi  communauté d'application de la loi dans
une conversation sur la façon d'utiliser les armes de manière
responsable et de désamorcer la violence
par opposition au meurtre de personnes de couleur
que si nous n'avons pas de bonnes lois sur le contrôle des armes à feu
, les gens mourront, nous continuerons à
voir des fusillades de masse au rythme que
nous avons vu en 2016 a  a été une
année déchirante pour les fusillades de masse, cela se produit presque
tous les jours aux États-Unis et donc dans ce sens,
je ne me sens pas en sécurité, nous allons être des
zombies dans le défilé et nous
aurons une voiture nommée
qui identifie chaque zombie comme  un
membre du Congrès, ils suivront des
membres de la NRA qui tiendront des
sacs d'argent et comme vous pouvez le voir, ils sont
éclaboussés de sang parce que c'est de l'
argent du sang, c'est de l'argent qui est
fait du c  ost de la vie humaine,
ce que nous savons, c'est que
lorsqu'il y a un tir de masse, les ventes d'armes à
feu augmentent et que ces fabricants d'armes et
ces unités de vente d'armes font que nos magasins d'armes
gagnent une tonne d'argent après avoir tiré un
massacre et puis il y a  des
sociétés de capital-investissement qui investissent dans ces sociétés d'armes à feu
qui gagnent ensuite de l'argent chaque fois
qu'il y a une fusillade de masse et nous appelons donc
cela l'argent du sang